يتحدث نتنياهو عن محور فيلادلفيا وكان
السيطره عليه ستنهي مشاكل حملته العسكريه
على غزه وعلى اساس ان السيطره على هذا
المحور ستكتب الامان والسلام لمواطني
اسرائيل اعتبر نتنياهو ان مسار الحرب
مرتبط بهذا المحور استمعوا لما
قال تصير فيلادلفيا من الواضح اننا لن
ننهي هذه الحرب دون اغلاق هذه الثغره
الجنوبيه والا فحتى لو قضينا على حماس
وجردن غزه من السلاح سيدخل مزيد من
الاسلحه ومزيد من المعدات الحربيه هناك
عدد من الخيارات بشان كيفيه اغلاقه نحن
ندرسها كلها لكننا لم نتخذ قرارا بعد
باستثناء شيء واحد يجب اغلاقه عدد من
الخيارات لاغلاق هذا المحور اذا اردتم
التعرف عليه فهو هذا المحور طوله 14 ك مت
عرضه بضعه مئات من الامتار يمتد من البحر
المتوسط شمالا حتى معبر كرم ابو سالم في
الجنوب يتوسطه معبر رفح كان تحت سيطره
اسرائيل حتى انسحابها من غزه عام 2005 بما
يعرف بخطه فك الارتباط المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه المصريه احمد ابو زيد رد على
تصريحات نتنياهو بشان محور فيلادلفيا في
مداخله مع قناه صد البلد
المصريه تضبط حدودها بشكل كامل وتسيطر على
ها بشكل كامل وهذه المسائل بتخضع
لاتفاقيات قانونيه وامنيه
بين الدول المعنيه وبالتالي يعني اي حديث
في هذا
الشان بشكل عام بيخضع ل التدقيق ويتم الرد
عليه بمواقف
معله طبعا ترتبط مصر مع اسرائيل بمعاهده
كام ديفيد لكن بروتوكول فيلادلفيا او محور
صلاح الدين هو بروتوكول منفصل
ويعني ملحق بهذه الاتفاقيه ولكن
يشكل مبدا منفصلا عنها لمياء تقول لا يمكن
باي حال من الاحوال ان تقبل مصر بما تطمح
اليه تل ابيب وهذا ما يدركه نتنياهو
ويحاول الضغط عن طريق واشنطن او وسيله
اخرى لتحقيق ذلك طارق محمد محور فيلادلفيا
مرتبط باتفاقيه سلام يعني اسرائيل لو
عايزه حرب بالعربي تنتهك الاتفاقيه وتتصرف
زي ما هي عايزه تتحمل مسؤوليه اي رد مصري
سواء عسكري او غيره احمد قال محور
فيلادليفيا يقع داخل غزه وليس على ارض
مصريه اي ان من يتحمل مسؤوليه الدفاع هو
حركه حماس الحاكم لقطاع غزه وضع قوات
اسرائليه كبيره فيه يشكل مخالفه لاتفاقيه
السلام اذا لم يكن بالتنسيق مع مصر مصطفى
قال لك ما علاقه السيطره على محور
فيلادلفيا بفوزي بالحرب حماس اصبحت تصنع
اسلحتها محليا حتى لو سيطر جيش الاحتلال
على محور فيلاديلفيا سيتعرض لاستنزاف كبير
خطه اسرائيل واهدافها في محور فيلاديلفيا
تربطها بمزاعم عن مصادر تسليح حماس لكن
ابو عبيده في خطابه الاخير قال غير هذا ان
جل ما قاومنا ونقاوم به عدوان الصهاينه هو
من صنع كتائب القسام من عبوات ناسفه
ومقذوفات صاروخيه وراجمات
ومدافع ومضادات للدروع وقنابل مختلف
انواعها وبنادق القنص وحتى
الرصاص وهذه الصناعات لم تكن لتجدي نفعا
امام الترسانه الامريكيه الهائله
القذره التي نواجهها في ايدي مرتزقه
الصهاينه في الميدان لولا الصناعه الاهم
التي نمتلكها وهي صناعه الانسان المقاتل